hello and thank you for joining me today
I'm Martin ladderich the chief
scientific officer of bioscale bioscale
is a company offering Integrated
Solutions in developing biomarker
immunoassays for using basic and
clinical research before I delve into my
presentation I'd like to declare a
financial conflict of interest as an
executive and shareholder of bioscale
furthermore I'll mention biomackers
associated with human disease and
technology for biomarker Discovery by no
means do I make claims as to their
suitability and use as an approved
diagnostic
with the legal disclaimer out of the way
I like to focus on what is rapidly
becoming an evolving medical practice
and and a paradigm shift that goes from
a classical Medical Practice uh to the
future of medicine so in the so-called
20th century empirical medicine you
would go visit your doctor was an
ailment or illness the doctor would
perform a symptom-based diagnostic
possibly an in vitro diagnostic or x-ray
Imaging and then based on the
physician's experience The Physician
would prescribe a treatment very often
for example when you go see a physician
The Physician would say something like
oh you have a sore throat it could be
bacterial here try this antibiotic if it
doesn't work come back in a few weeks
and then we'll try something different
and very often you would either recover
or revisit your physician
where Medical Practice is evolving in
the 21st century
so-called the Precision medicine
Paradigm you would visit your physician
The Physician would already know your
genetic profile and would diagnose
phenotypic links to disease and the
physician would basically say well we
can monitor your progression of disease
or we can prescribe some preventative
programs
and then you would
have a targeted diagnostic assay or an
in vitro diagnostic SEO Imaging which
enables The Physician to prescribe the
relevant treatment and then during the
treatment you would use a again a in
vitro diagnostic or Imaging to monitor
the progression of disease on this is
very very relevant to cancer because
cancer is a genetic disease that uh
basically goes that basically proceeds
with the
um the development of a tumor a tumor
which is the due to a genetic aberration
and then the tumor will go out of the
control and all the tumor development
and human growth is associated with
changes in the molecular makeup of both
the genome as well as the proteome of of
the tumor so I think their medicine is
rapidly progressing is there's a much
broader rational basis that is
developing in order to precisely
understand the cause of the disease and
hopefully have the relevant therapeutic
that goes goes along so so that is
basically what is known as Precision
medicine
and so very important for the Paradigm
of precision medicine is the actual
ability to diagnose a condition and and
this ability is a basically driven by
biomarkers biomackers are molecules that
have an association with a specific
disease for example cystic fibrosis is a
caused by a mutation in a chloride
Channel and so the aberrant Gene of the
chloride channel is a biomarker for the
disease like cystic fibrosis
not all biomarkers are genomic in origin
some of them it can be proteins or small
molecules for example a a good biomarker
for a hemoglobin disorder such as beta
thalassemia is actually the protein the
hemoglobin itself and so a biomarker can
also be a protein that is either causing
the disease or that is associated with a
disease
you make a
discrimination between biomarkers that
are mechanistically linked to a disease
these biomarkers are generally
mechanistic biomarkers they're directly
involved in the disease process
or biomarkers can also be associated
with a disease but not causing the
disease and these biomarkers would be
termed surrogate biomarkers
now how do you go on discovering
biomarkers so the in in very simplistic
terms you would look for differences
between healthy individuals or diseased
patients and you would would see what
are the
molecular differences between both
patient and healthy individual
and so it's a very simplistic
Paradigm to go screening and looking for
differences
now at the same time every human being
is molecularly very distinct from one
another they share share very similar
genomic negats but at the same time they
are exposed to different environments
they're exposed to a different history
and all this can cause differences in
the molecular makeups between a patient
and healthy individuals and so not all
differences between healthy individuals
and patients are actually biomarkers for
the disease of a patient and so the
generally accepted uh a definition is of
biomarker Discovery is
finding differences among for example
messenger RNA proteins protein
modifications and metabolites between
health and disease is actually quite
easy so it's very easy and because we
have outstanding molecular tools that
allow us to measure these various
biomarkers however and that is something
really important to remember when you go
on and discover biomarkers many of such
differences are random or nutritional
very few differences can be validated
across many patients in a functional
surrogate biomarkers and that is
actually one of the reasons why uh in
the last 20 years or so uh actually that
not very many new biomarkers that made
it into a clinical practice and that was
in in part due to the either technology
is not being available or the emphasis
on validation wasn't really there and so
it's only in recent years that we see a
new uh a number of biomarkers for
disease that are have been coming to the
market today
so uh what is needed for for precision
medicine a biomarkers that can predict
the disease outcome or diagnosed at an
early stage simply looking for
differences is not enough but the
discovery actually has to be followed by
extensive validation
so when you look at the traditional
biomarker research pipeline you can
discriminate between Discovery phase you
can discriminate between validation
phase and then ultimately the desired
outcome of a biomarker discovery and
validation effort is actually the
development of a diagnostic assay
and so they are different
fundamentally different tools that are
being employed to discover biomarkers
that is looking for Meaningful
differences between healthy and diseased
individuals some of these Solutions are
most of these Solutions are actually
Mass spectrometry based because the mass
spectrometer is an excellent platform to
interrogate molecular differences
between two different samples
and some of the last decade has focused
on optimizing the Technologies
to statistically significant to to
describe a different biomarkers that are
statistically as significance so looking
for statistic differences between say a
healthy a tissue and a tumor tissue some
of these methods which I will mention
later on relate to eye track which is a
method uh say a mass spectrometry method
that employs isobaric mass tags that
allow you to trace
materials and peptides and proteins from
different samples but it's only one
method out of many different ways to
actually look at the differential
proteomic Mega
and then they're they're uh somewhat uh
other methods for example protein
microwaves and cellular profiling which
quite frequently used in the past but
which are currently been displaced by uh
more uh accurate Solutions
the validation phase
uh is divided into two sections the
first one is an analytical validation
which means you're actually confirming
that what you measured as a difference
is actually the protein that you think
you measure it so it's an analytical
validation usually requires orthogonal
methods of validation or or measurement
and then there's also the clinical
validation which basically takes all
your analytically validated biomarker
candidates and it uh tests them against
a very large cohort of a clinical
specimens and so it's the clinical
validation ultimately that serves to
confirm or dispute your original
hypothesis that one of these many
differences is actually linked to a
disease it's actually quite interesting
many of the biomarkers out there but
they actually fail at the clinical
validation state just because maybe the
clinical cohort being used was uh not
not not proper uh maybe because there
was a bias in selecting patients so all
this can lead to failure of a clinical
validation
and so uh Discovery experiments in in a
clinical diagnostic asset development uh
definitely can generate many candidate
biomarkers which will ultimately need to
be analytically and clinically validated
actually in the whole commercial
Discovery process the validation phase
is probably the most expensive phase of
any biomarker development and diagnostic
assay development project
and then lastly once you have a
clinically validated biomarker or panel
of biomarkers that you then would go
onto a diagnostic assay development and
so for Diagnostic asset development
what's really critical I is you have to
actually know what you're measuring so
you have to really test and make sure
your analytical method is compatible
with the specimen that has been
generated in the clinic and so for
Diagnostic asset development accurate
quantification with statistical
confidence is really really important
and some of the solutions are so
classical Solutions mostly based on
Eliza assays but more recently uh the
Next Generation elizo type platforms or
mass spectrometry measurements that
ultimately will will hopefully result in
a more accurate uh clinical diagnostic
assays so just looking at the bottom
part of the slide here during Discovery
ideally you want to measure everything
that is in a sample so you're using a
broad Mass spectrometry approach whereas
when you have a clinically relevant
diagnostic assay you generate generally
many samples but you have very few
biomarkers that actually pass the
validation test
so that summarizes the uh traditional
biomarker research pipeline
so what I'd like to do next is uh focus
on a biomarker a discovery project that
some of my clinical collaborators and
myself
performed many years ago and so that
showcases how you would go on to
discovering a biomarker that is relevant
to a particular disease
and so the a disease of interest is a
chronic vinyl sinusitis and uh the
common chronic is a very common chronic
disease it leads to impairment and
quality of life and also leads to
significant health care costs so this
chronic virus anositis is not the kind
of a sinusitis you face that is cured by
antibiotics it's actually the a chronic
condition that leads to Patient
continuously suffering from Amino
sinusitis and this particular disease at
the time it wasn't really unclear what
actually causes that and how it
distinguishes itself from a regular
Rhino sinusitis
and uh there's also other than a
surgical procedures there's no Curative
treatment there was no Curative
treatment at the time when the uh
Discovery
was done and it's actually the third
most common chronic disease in uh uh
urine and and in a nose
and uh also uh so so what we then did
was that we decided to uh go to a small
cohort of patients that consisted of
healthy individuals people suffering
from lino sinusitis and people diagnosed
as being suffering from chronic vinyl
sinusitis and so what we did was we
employed a methodology and it's called
eye track which is a differential
labeling technology that allows you to
compare different samples using a mass
spectrometer and so the way you would
perform an eye track analysis is you
would take a clinical sample for example
the sample will be used in in our case
was a mucus that was extracted after a
sinusoidal intubation and this mucus was
digested with an enzyme that generates
smaller peptides so the enzyme we used
was trypsin and the trypsin was used to
generate smaller peptides that are
compatible with mass spectrometry
analysis
so once we had digested samples
originating from different individuals
into a small tryptic peptides we
performed individual labeling isobaric
labeling of these samples with a eye
track label so so this particular label
allows you to add a defined Mass to each
peptide and and this defined mass is
able to actually Define or
allow you to assign which sample the
peptide that have this additional Mass
attached to it which sample these
peptides originated from and and that is
used it's a pooling method so you would
basically then take your individually
tagged peptides originating from
different patients and you would then
combine them and perform a separation
using hplc chromatography and then you
would use a mass spectrometer an LC msms
to determine what these peptides are and
then what allows you to do when you're
using msms mode which means you take
these peptides and you you break them
down even further it allows you actually
uh to decide firstly that the mass
spectrometer tells you which peptide of
it is what the actual peptide sequences
the amino acid sequence and also it
gives you the so-called eye track
isobaric Mass tags which tell you how
abundant each peptide was in each sample
so for example here The Identical
peptide was most abundant in Sample
number three whereas in Sample number
one it was least abundant uh so so this
methodology allows you to Multiplex and
simultaneously compare uh different
samples it's a common Mass spectrometry
approach and the reason uh multiplexing
is useful Because the actual analytical
process of mass spectrometry is actually
quite expensive and so if you have to
pay for operator time multiplexing
allows you to deepen the process
so this is actually what an hplc Trace
looks like so this graph basically shows
the illusionable sample from a hvlc
chromatography a column and so if we
zoom in on the peptide it's eluded at 34
minutes and we submit this peptide to
mass spectrometer analysis uh we
actually uh I can isolate the three as
strong as signals that correspond to
peptide that's characterized by by this
Mass spectrometer Mass spectrogram which
actually defines the sequence of the
peptide and then if we uh zoom in on the
reporter ions from the eye track label
we now know exactly how abundant this
particular peptide was in a different
individuals so so we see here individual
two at least abundance whereas
individual number four had the highest
abundance in in this particular test
and so at this particular peptide
actually corresponds to a prototypic
peptide that is found in
anti-leukoproteinase one pre-truster
and so by performing this analysis uh
the mass spectrometer allows you to tell
how about firstly what types of patterns
were found in the sample it also allows
you to determine which peptides were
overexpressed or reduced in expression
and so uh so that allows you to see to
study molecular differences between
these two or more
mucous samples
so if we uh actually look at the uh list
of down regulated proteins the protein
that is uh down regulated actually one
of the most prominent proteins is done
regulated in chronic final sinusitis
patients is actually the precursor to
lysozyme C
and it's a protein which functions in
the innate immune response so uh it's
actually a bacteriolytic enzyme that
equates a certain microbes and so having
a reduction in this particular enzyme in
the patient it suggests or allows us to
develop a hypothesis that may be if this
kind of lysozyme is reduced in a large
number of patients maybe these patients
develop the condition because they are
innate immune response is negatively
affected
uh the other protein which is done
regulated in patients is a clearer
self-phospholipid binding protein and
it's a potent inhibitor of phospholipase
A2 and so here it's actually quite
interesting because actually
phospholipase A2 is a pro-inflammatory
enzyme and so uh so if you inhibit this
enzyme
you reduce inflammation whereas if you
actually have a low concentration of the
enzyme inhibitor it may even promote
inflammation so that could be a reason
for a specific reason for that so just
by looking at molecular differences
between healthy and disease individuals
you're actually able to develop a novel
hypotheses that you could test during a
future validation study similarly I mean
you have seen upregulated proteins for
example calc granulin B migration
inhibitory Factor related protein 14
which is a inhibitor of protein kinases
so so maybe uh maybe that actually uh
also favors inflammation
so uh basically I just showed this
type of effort
to see kind of to Showcase what is
involved in discovering a biomarkers I
think the most critical component is
actually uh you want to discover
something that is significant to disease
so the most important thing is you have
to have samples derived from well
characterized patients
and I need very good analytical tools
for screening but then more importantly
the screening part is actually the
analytical validation part because it
requires a different type of method to
go in so the current methods employed
for the validation actually showing the
validation important to determine that
these biomarkers are actually really the
biomocracy itself Network and so so the
two methods that are currently employed
are a so-called SRM and mrm message it
stands for single reaction monitoring or
multiple reaction monitoring which is a
mass spectrometry method and uh the
other major validation tool is the Elisa
assay or immunoassay which is
inexpensive but that that's required
antibodies I think the chief difference
also is that SRM and mrm are not very
sensitive whereas elizas can be
exceptionally sensitive so if you buy a
market of Interest there's no abundance
which many of the oncology biomarkers
are you actually have to employ a method
that is able to uh measure the potential
biomarker of interest for example in
early cancer detection detection
uh quickly uh mentioning mrm type
methodologies so mrm is a mass
declamatory method and uh for in order
to develop an mrm I say you have to know
the sequence of the protein of Interest
so you then perform an in Silicon digest
so you're basically using a computer to
generate all the possible tryptic
peptides and then you select the peptide
of interest that is unique and that
uniquely characterizes the protein of
interest and these type of peptides they
call it called proteotypic peptides and
then you do a mass spectrometry
detection and a quantification and in
some instances you may even do an AMS
spectrometry confirmation of of the
micro of interest and so the the benefit
of this particular method is it does not
require
antibodies however it is not sensitive
live enough for some of the biomarkers
and so so basically multiple reaction
monitoring it's very can be very
specific and sensitive for detecting
components in the complex to make sure
but in terms of analytical sensitivity
uh it may not go into the picogram per
ml or sub people gram per male range
that is required for some of the uh
biomarkers that are of clinical
significance
the m method has the largest linear
dynamic range for a qualification and
it's commonly performed by a mass
spectrometer as as a follower as an
analytical validation and but it does
require some somewhat more sophisticated
mass spectrometers that are relatively
expensive
and an example from my own previous work
in the area of
neurodegeneration and muscular
degeneration we develop a proteotypic
assay that measures p97 peptides and p97
is a protein which is involved in muscle
degeneration and neurodegeneration and
we developed nasae that allows us to
measure a unique proteolytic product of
p97 using a mass spectrometer and and
this shows the complexity of of the
involvement so we basically generate an
hplc Trace we show the actual
Mass Spectrum then we show the extracted
ion and the confirmatory msms Spectrum
to confirm the sequence so you can
employ these type of tests for uh
validating analytically validating
biomarkers
now the other uh fundamental
fundamentally different technology is
actually uh in immuno asset development
so if you're if you your research has
generated a um another biomarker and you
have antibodies that are available to
recognize that biomarker and the first
thing you would do is you would do a
develop an immunoassay so that could be
an Elisa or as shown in in this
particular example it could be a an amp
assay and so what you would do is it
would screen for antibodies that show
good pairing so for most amino acids you
would want to choose a uh a sandwich
assay for added specificity and
sensitivity but there are many many
different antibodies available against
your favorite uh
a potential biomarker of interest and
the best first strategy is to see which
of these many antibodies in combination
gives you the best signal to noise ratio
and so here this particular example
showcases the development of an
anti-phospho P38 assay and you see that
amongst many different antibodies that
are commercially available
there's a smaller number here that shows
a really good pairing that means they
give you a very good signal to noise
ratio
uh and and the uh these type of assays
can be your traditional plate Eliza
assay or the Next Generation type assay
such as the acoustic membrane
mycoparticle assay and and this shows
the principle of this type of asset
technology they would take a homogenous
uh which is based on homogenous beat
assets so in this particular instance
you would take a magnetic beat that has
capture anal capture antibodies that
capture your analyte of interest and you
have a cognate detection antibody with a
heptin tank attached to it you would
pre-mix or pre-incubate uh this type of
analytical assay mix with your clinical
sample of Interest
and then I would take this mixture and
flow it across a uh a sensor in this
case it's an acoustic a sensor surface
that measures the mass deposition which
can be is proportional to the amount of
mass deposited to the membrane and in
this particular case it would take the
magnetic beads and the reaction mix and
use a magnet to attract all the beads to
the sensor to the acoustic sensor
surface and then uh these uh and then we
were disengage the magnet and only
specifically Associated beads will
remain at the sensor surface whereas all
non-specifically uh Associated beats
would flow away in a buffer stream and
the principle of an acoustic assay is
based on the fact that when you have a
resonant acoustic membrane so the
membrane resonates at a high frequency
and you deposit Mass to this membrane it
will lead to a slowing of the vibration
which can be measured and and this
measurement is directly proportional to
the amount of protein deposited so if
you have a standard curve uh in in these
type of assays it allows you uh by
comparing your analytical results
comparing it to your standard curve it
allows you to exactly determine the
concentration of your analyte of
interest in the sample
and uh this type of assays that can be
done in a sandwich format so you
basically have an antibody which is uh
either directly or indirectly linked to
a magnetic bead these antibodies will
recognize your biomarker or Target
protein of Interest
and you have a cognitive detection
antibody which has a heptin attached and
this happened can can form an
interaction with an anti-aptin sensor
surface so that's the sub principle of
sandwich assays you can use a
competition assays or immunocompetitive
assays in cases where you only have a
single antibody against your antigen of
Interest they are dealing with a small
molecule or a single epitope Target
proteins or a biomarker analyze and so
it's a different assay format that can
be used to measure that
now very often in uh in in sorry this
this this one example uh of an uh
acoustic immunoassay against the uh il-6
analyte and that shows you uh asset
parameters such as the lower limit of
detection so so using these type of
assays uh you can measure sub picogram
per ml levels of uh interesting
biomarkers such as the
pro-inflammatory uh cytokine
interleukin-6 and then uh important for
um
assays are also validation criteria for
example you want want your assay to show
a certain characteristic that indicate
the assay is not easily uh interfered by
other analytes that may be contaminating
a sample so you have during the
development of these type of assays you
use a specific criteria to rule out your
assay measures other proteins interest
and just to Showcase
some of the discovery studies that that
have been done that have appeared in a
recent uh scientific literature I wanted
to highlight two specific studies here
the first study is by adona at Al which
actually describes a discovery effort to
discover potentially novel biomarkers in
a myocardial infarction now
um traditionally what has happened is uh
most Discovery efforts in heart disease
they focused on historic blood samples
that were taken from healthy individuals
and compared it to individuals that had
a myocardial infarction event however it
has always been very very difficult to
actually use blood or plasma to discover
a novel and markers
most importantly that is or the most
likely explanation for that is that
plasma and blood in general can be a
very a poor method of
detecting biomarkers
and uh so so this particular study uh
the reason I want to highlight it
actually shows something very
interesting and that is it's actually a
study that was done in a procedure that
induces uh heart attacks or controlled
heart attacks in a certain type of
patients and so it's a procedure that
exposes a small region in the patient's
heart to ethanol to induce a myocardial
infarction event which and then this
particular study actually
took a blood from the patient
immediately before the procedure during
the procedure and after the procedure so
you had a sample like like a healthy
sample that despite the patient State
before myocardial before Plant
myocardial infarction and then it it was
able to generate several samples during
and after look proceed teacher and so
but you don't have to worry about in
these so-called autologous type assay
procedures is uh you actually don't have
to worry about patient variability which
is actually quite significant so so
meaning whenever you saw a difference in
this particular patient in a plasma
based biomarker profile you knew it was
caused by the procedure and so samples
were taken basically a baseline 10
minutes 60 Minutes 240 minutes and
1440 minutes so that's that's a very
very good example a powerful example how
you can use the same patient to describe
differences that happen over time like
in this case over the procedure
and I don't really have much time to go
into the study and this reference later
on that you could go and see uh how um
how this particular Discovery initiative
was done and so those kind of so-called
autologous Discovery efforts they kind
of neutralize the need for a large
patient cohort which you would have to
do uh to be statistically significant if
you didn't have the same patient or the
same patient Baseline and that is
because a different people have can have
a significant differences in biomarket
profiles especially in Blood and plasma
uh the other study um that I wanted to
highlight is actually a biomarker
discovery study uh that was performed by
Taylor
and and this one was a study that
focused on discovering uh breast cancer
biomarkers and this particular study was
was quite different in a sense that it
used a hypothesis driven a rational
approach to define what could potential
biomodules be that uh relate to breast
cancer and so so this particular case
they did not do what many many other uh
people in the West Central field have
done that is comparing uh blood samples
of
um Halcyon diseased individuals but in
this particular case the investigators
asked the question what has the
literature shown what what are the
proteins that may be relevant to
progression of a breast cancer so they
they basically came up with a can end of
the list that included proteins
affiliated with breast cancer that also
included surface proteins commonly found
on a breast tumors and then they
developed a mass spectrometer assays
that selectively looked for these
particular markers these candidate
markers to see how many of those could
actually be detected and more
importantly how many of those would be a
differentially expressed and could
discriminate between halcy and disease
individuals and and this actually a
study that wasn't done on patients but
on Mouse models of breast cancer
and then after they I came up with a
candidate list or they never done a
candid list from uh almost 2 000
candidate markers to about five 572
markers they used SRM assays and immuno
as a Rema says to actually uh come up
with a a kind of small list of
biomarkers that that are currently being
further analyzed
so so that's another way uh biomarker
Discovery these days is uh has has
changed from only several years ago in a
sense that people use many more uh
hypothesis driven approaches as opposed
to a simple screening approaches
and just to show uh but what it would
take to perform something like this uh
you're uh actually uh looking at your
initial Discovery takes several months
to perform a targeted quantification uh
takes another uh five months and then
ultimately uh coming up with a good
quantitative essays can take take
anything close close to a year and the
cost of these type of assays is actually
quite uh quite significant
so uh so the key for Discovery and
validation is uh that's something a lot
of people underestimate is uh you have
to start with a well-defined a patient
and control cohort
because actually there are many studies
that have been performed over the last
10 years that showed that a really
simple procedures such as for example
taking blood from a patient where the
patient is sitting up versus the patient
the client on uh on on a bed
just the position of drawing your blood
can lead to significantly a changed
profiles
concurrent was as the sampling method uh
you need a unified strict sampling
procedures for example when you perform
a surgical extraction of a tumor it
makes a huge difference if the tumor is
immediately snap Frozen or if it sits on
an operating in an operating room for 20
minutes or half hour so so not having
this type of processes like sampling
defined is actually a recipe for a a
poor differential discovery of
biomarkers so so it's really really
critical a strict sample preparation
lessons uh also if a patient allows for
the possibility of autogenic specimen
collection that actually can enhance the
discovery initiative because you're
eliminating uh genomic and phenotypic
differences
and then one thing to always remember is
in in proteomic Discovery patient
individuality sampling and Sample
preparation can account for the majority
of proteomic differences and so
ultimately all these potential
differences have to be validated to to
be really certain or to ascertain that
these differences are actually due to
the uh a disease
and uh very often even for blood-based
biomarkers people now go to use tissue
that are relevant to the disease
assuming that some of the tissue
proteins are shed either directly or
through exosomes and that avoids the
blind screening of plasma which
historically has been very very
difficult
so the last few minutes I wanted to
touch on aspects of clinical validation
so a clinical validation is defined as
actually uh
screening the a number of patients that
have been diagnosed with a relevant
disease such as cancer or specific
subtype of cancer and basically in order
to do clinical validation you have to
build assays that allow you to do so at
least analytical assays many of these
assays actually require the selection
characterization of antibodies that
Faithfully can measure your candidate
biomarker in in a clinical validation
Style
generally it requires large screens to
select antibody species that can
recognize the analyte and that are not
affected by other Matrix interferences
that might be present in your sample
uh it can require extensive kinetic
characterization of antibody of affinity
Affinity selectivity and specificity
and uh some some instances you may
actually have to synthesize or make an
antibody uh that needs to be extensively
characterized because sometimes
conjugation can affect antibody
properties and so uh it just shows that
actually
um a clinical validation although it's
very intuitive actually the
um fundamental work required to to build
assays is actually quite immense and
that links to the cost of developed
assets and uh most important to remember
is that uh most of the biomarket
candidates they actually fail at the
stage of a clinical validation and so
that imposes the question uh if you and
and your particular team or effort has
one or two biomarkers that uh May relate
to a uh uh a clinical case or may relate
to a specific type of cancer
developing assays for those biomarkers
there's no guarantee that actually these
biomarkers will really be uh uh a link
to the disease and so uh some larger
initiatives maybe Community Driven
initiatives that take a whole collect
collection of candidate biomarkers from
different uh studies and developing a
validation cohort could really
streamline the process so you don't have
to individually use a well-defined
patient and and use up radar disease
material but you could maximize the
impact by taking the whole Community
biomarker candidates and then looking at
one really really well characterized
cohort to see if one or more or any of
these candidate markers hold the test of
clinical validation
you know once you your your
um biomacker has passed the test of a
clinical validation uh you would
generally develop a a diagnostic test
and so that can be a test that is either
run in a service lab such as a as clear
laboratory or it can be a test that can
be offered on a approved diagnostic
platform and so uh most of the current
proteomic diagnostic tests related to
cancer it actually requires a selection
characterization of antibodies because
most of these tests are antibody based
require a very very specific assay
characterization so to understand
interferences because you want to make
sure when you have a clinical essay that
your assay actually measures the analyte
of interest and so so that they
established methodologies that allow you
to do so to basically Define the degree
of interference and the profile of
interfere runs that may affect your
immunoassay of clinical significance it
requires the following of established
validation guidelines and many of these
assays can be run under a a cap
certified clear lab so that's something
many companies do with in an oncology
field they like to run their assays and
the clear first because it actually
gives them the opportunity to do a lot
of development work but also to get more
experience with the type of say that has
been run and that can lead to a better
validation of the assay and then once
the assay has been
properly validated against a larger
cohort of individuals these assays could
be offered as a 510k type approved
assays but very often coupled to a
diagnostic device
so uh interesting summary uh the promise
of predictive and diagnostic biomarkers
is uh is manifold uh they're better
better diagnosis in early in the
intervention uh is is really uh
important when you treat cancer because
very often cancer is an individual
disease that is made up of individual
genomic and proteomic differences and
only recognizing and measuring these
differences they'll have a major impact
on a tree on patient treatment
also biomarkers are required for more
efficient drug development so for
example uh patient stratification and
lastly uh you can by having a biomarker
driven type uh uh Diagnostic and
therapeutic approaches they could really
significantly eliminate the empirical
approach that I mentioned earlier on
so I just wanted to give you a number of
key papers for further reading if you'd
like to go more into the uh biomarker a
discovery type approaches I think in
terms of discovery of biomarkers I like
to highlight the two papers by adona and
Al that were published nature
biotechnology in 2011 and by white tiger
and Al also published in the same
industry of nature biotech and then also
for a clinical asset development and
unfortunately it didn't really have much
time to delve in into that today I
wanted to highlight the paper by taguchi
and hanash that really very nicely
outlined the steps required for uh
actual clinical diagnostic assay
development in in the area of cancer
I'd like to acknowledge our past and
present members of my research team some
of which contributed to the uh slides
that are shown today on a discovery and
an immuno asset development and I'd like
to leave you as the uh continuing
education URL and so that is something
if you want to obtain your continuing
education credits uh you would go to uh
to this particular link I'd like to stop
here and take any questions
uh the first question
is actually what is the minimum sample
size required to validate a biomarker as
a diagnostic tool it's a very very
interesting question and the answer is
uh well the simple answer is as many as
possible because you only will see
um you only have really good statistical
power the more samples you have in many
instances in a world of oncology that is
not very practical and so generally what
I've seen in in the discovery
initiatives is uh you would start a
discovery of uh biomarkers in a
relatively small cohort of patients so
if it's a common cancer I typically see
somewhere between uh 40 and 50
individuals that have the disease and
maybe between between 20 and 40 healthy
equivalents
and those usually make up a discovery
cohorts now it also depends on the
genetic or proteomic diversity of the
cancer patient versus the healthy
individuals so for example in advice
cancer there are many many different
molecularly defined cancers the
discovery cohorts would have to be
significantly a larger and so I think uh
so the answer is if it's a relatively
homogeneous type of tumor you're looking
in different individuals you look in the
dozens But ultimately
um you you'll have to look in a larger
cohorts now they're
um
number of instances for example in
pediatric cancers they are the cancer is
relatively rare and so it becomes very
very difficult to actually do these
large Discovery initiatives and so very
often uh but uh you would want to do is
you take some really well characterized
patient and then you see can you obtain
autologous material for example can you
extract part of the tumor and extract
part of an equivalent tissue that mimics
the developmental stage and program of
of the actual tumor
in best instances of course you always
look at autologous type type samples in
which case uh you actually can use lower
number of cohorts
um the other question is uh can you
um uh think of successful examples of
transcript expression as biomarkers as
potent level a more accurate measure of
biological events such as disease
development and progression a very
interesting question as well because
cancer is actually defined as a genetic
disease and so it's actually very
straightforward to look for uh
translocations that are associated with
tumors or mutations that uh in Signal
transaction components and that relate
to a progression of cancer and so these
kind of genomic uh
examples definitely exist they're
actually part of a diagnostic or
clinical practice today for example one
assay that uses transcripts is the
genomic Health marketed assay which
looks for a transcripts that allow you
to discriminate between different types
of breast cancer
now the field of breast cancer is a good
example that you basically need both a
genomic and polyomic components for
example you would use a genomic Health
profile looking at transcripts and where
I see what I use a immunohistochemistry
type type methodology to to actually
investigate the her2 status of the tumor
so I think in oncology both methods are
equally uh well used
um I think there's a uh from from a
genomic point of view it's very often
easier to look at genomic differences
however there's certain polyamic
differences that I link to the disease
and the etiology of the disease for
example her2 classical example in
oncology and also when you make a
treatment decision very often it becomes
important to actually understand which
of the many parts possible signal
transduction pathways are
responsible for a growth addiction of
the tumor and so by understanding the
proteomic profile of the signal
transaction nodes of these type of
tumors it should make making treatment
decisions easier as opposed to just
looking at a transcript so I would say
in summary it very much depends on the
tumor in the type of decision that that
has been made
and a number of
cases uh there's a developing Trend that
goes towards looking into uh this of
classical plasma based proteomic
biomarkers that indicate the presence
and absence of a tumor for example in uh
there's effort in uh individuals that
have ovarian cancer to actually
establish a baseline of ca125 which is a
classical marker for ovarian cancer and
it would follow the uh diminishment of a
ca125 level as the tumor responds to
treatment it's very difficult to use
ca125 as a pure diagnostic marker
because individuals actually can vary
with their basal ca125 level but
actually if you follow individuals over
time you could make a certain kind of a
decision based on these type of
proteomic markers
there are no more questions I'd like to
thank the audience and the organizers
and I'd be happy to take additional
questions by email